a big Supreme Court decision struck down
affirmative action
in college admissions
specifically against Harvard and UNC and
this case only really was able to go
through because the Discrimination was
directed not only toward white people
but also toward Asian students had this
just been about discriminating against
white people I don't think the court
would have struck it down because we
just live in a culture where white
people are denigrated they are not only
legally discriminated against but also
the culture encourages uniquely of white
people to be denigrated insulted called
you know the worst people in the world
and the courts read the newspapers and
they watch the election returns and I
think probably affirmative action would
have remained in place
had it only been about white people but
the libs got greedy and they attacked
Asian people because Asians have the
highest test scores which really
undermines a lot of the narrative around
white privilege and whatever other
nonsense the lips talk about so because
this case could be framed as
one racial minority being oppressed
uh by I guess another racial minority
oppressor or something because the white
people didn't really factor into it too
much affirmative action gets struck down
and I celebrated this and I said wow
this is great news it had just broken
when I came on air but but I said you
know the one bit of caution I'll give
you here is
the schools are going to continue to
discriminate they're just going to do so
by reducing the importance of objective
measures and standardized tests and
they're going to inflate the importance
of say the personal statement and these
these more ambiguous criteria for
college admissions such that if you say
you know I am I am an oppressed person
black lives matter black lives matter in
your personal statement then that will
be given greater weight
and that's how the schools will continue
to discriminate against whites and
probably Asians too well
I really do hate to say I told you so
here Harvard already proved me right
within hours
Harvard sent out this notice dear
members of the Harvard community
today the Supreme Court delivered its
decision in students for fair admissions
versus president fellows of Harvard
College the Court held at Harvard
College admission system does not comply
with the principles of the equal
protection Clause embodied in the title
title VI of the Civil Rights Act the
court also ruled that colleges and
universities
may consider in admissions decisions
quote an applicant's discussion of how
race affected his or her life be it
through discrimination inspiration or
otherwise
we will certainly comply with the
Court's decision
and there you go there it is
I I did not predict that they would
admit to this so openly
but they did it makes me feel good that
they basically said dear members of the
Harvard Community the thing Michael said
on his show is exactly what we're gonna
do so I get a kick out of that I like I
like being right about these predictions
but
that's really on the nose it's so Brazen
it's it's it makes a mockery of the
Supreme Court in the system of law and
that's amazing coming from one of our
nation's most prestigious universities
they would say yeah
an applicant we can ask an applicant to
discuss how race has affected his or her
life so you know that's what they're
going to put on the application now say
how okay we can't ask what race you are
or we can't force you to tell us this
and we can't we can't give weight to you
know if you're black you get an extra
200 points or something and if you're a
whiter Asian you lose 200 points but we
can
give an outsized weight to this question
how is race affected your life and just
depending on how we feel about your
answer that's going to affect it so
Harvard is saying we are going to
continue to discriminate against white
people and against Asian people in
Admissions and Supreme Court you can go
pound sand right now go to cinch.com use
promo code Knowles Fourth of July is
upon us with many wonderful family
gatherings popping up the last thing
that you need when hosting your family
is turning on the grill and being out of
propane
that would be terrible that's where our
friends at cinch come in cinch's propane
grill tank Home Delivery Service they
deliver propane tanks right to your door
on your schedule they do not require any
long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
track the order on the Cinch app from
anywhere the perfect summer night would
not be complete without cinch go online
to cinch.com or download the Cinch app
to order new customers can get their
first tank exchange for just 10 bucks
with promo code Knowles cinch.com or
download the Cinch app use promo code
nulls to get your first tank exchange
for just 10 bucks this is a limited time
offer you must live within a cinched
service area to redeem it visit
cinch.com right now slash offer for
details and make sure that you sign up
summer is here baby it's the fourth of
July do not even have to think about
your propane tanks cinch.com promo code
Knowles other schools have been saying a
similar thing I think we've got another
one here yeah so this this uh some
coverage this is from Danielle Ren Holly
president of Mount Holyoke College
will it become more opaque this
application process yes it will have to
it's a complex process and this opinion
will make it even more complex I mean it
won't make it more complex in the
outcome which is whites and Asians will
be discriminated against black people
and other racial groups will have an
advantage and they're just going to do
it in a way that's a little bit more
complex they're going to have to ask a
long answer question instead of just
checking a box but that that will
continue and so forget about the college
admissions forget about the race uh
discrimination question for a second
this pose is a great challenge to our
entire system of Law and Order and it
accelerates a trend that we've seen for
years now which is nobody has faith in
our system of law anymore nobody has
faith in our institutions and the
Republicans are blamed for this because
the Republicans are the
insurrectionists from January 6 the
worst day in American history but
more much more than the Republicans and
the conservative it's it's the Liberals
and the Democrats who have undermined
our system
of Law and Order and our political
institutions they've questioned many
more elections for far flimsier reasons
than the conservatives had from much
longer time they've undermined our
system of law and they've turned our
system of law which is supposed to be
primarily a matter of interpretation
interpreting
Eternal principles of Justice in the
natural law and applying them to
changing political circumstances in our
positive civil law they've changed that
to merely an act of the will no we're
not we're not going to say that there's
any objective moral order or natural law
or anything that's all bunk we're just
going to impose whatever the hell we
want through whatever legal mechanisms
we possibly can unjust though they may
be well by doing that you undermine our
our
faith in the system of justice the idea
that lady Justice is blind with her
scales no that's gone now Justice will
be meted out uh more intensely to
political enemies and more leniently to
political friends you see this even in
the construction of courtrooms
courtrooms used to be gigantic think of
the Supreme Court building in Washington
DC big sturdy marble temples unchanging
heavy and now what are they they're tiny
little brutalist office rooms with low
ceilings where you don't feel that
weight of the law and the weight of
history and the unchanging
questions and principles of Justice
feels like any other bureaucrats office
where things can change on a diamond
frequently
they do and that's the libs doing that
and it's now being pushed by supposedly
one of the most prestigious colleges in
the country you can expect all the other
colleges to follow suit boy that was a
great clip I know I agree make sure that
you get more of them by subscribing here
to the Michael Knowles YouTube channel
ring the bell we'll see you next time